start off by reading by reading
something that you may not have heard
this this just came out the other day in
the Journal of the American Institute of
Biological Sciences and I quote
scientists have a moral obligation to
clearly warn humanity of any
catastrophic threat and to tell it like
it is on the basis of this obligation we
declared with more than 11,000 scientist
signatories from around the world
clearly and unequivocally that planet
Earth is facing a climate emergency this
is a climate emergency that's why we are
here to join the student climate
strikers in their efforts to allows more
and more people to the urgency of the
climate crisis and the need for activism
on an unprecedented scale so thank you
thank you for being here and it is for
military power and oil which created
Isis and Isis in turn is bankrolled by
fossil fuel fossil fuel
Trump says he wants to end the endless
wars but if if they're about war he has
no intention if they're about oil he has
no intention of ending them he betrayed
our Kurdish allies leaving them
vulnerable to Turkish attacks even while
he said our troops back in this into
Syria to protect oil the climate the
environment millions of people and
species are being killed because of oil
and in case you didn't know the Pentagon
is the biggest institutional user of
fossil fuel in the world
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm going to introduce Ben Cohen and
Jerry Greenfield activist philanthropist
and cofounders of the ice cream company
Ben and Jerry
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank Jane and most incredibly for
putting her body on the line showing us
the way that it's gonna be necessary for
us to put our bodies on the line also
[Applause]
you know the absurdity of spending over
50 percent of our nation's discretionary
budget on the Pentagon while the major
threat to our country is the climate
crisis is just kind of unbelievable
you know the amount of money that's
spent on the Pentagon over 700 billion
dollars a year is unfathomable but if it
were used for things that really helped
instead of wars that actually have the
effect of creating more terrorists we
can actually go a long way toward
improving what is really our national
security I mean our national security is
a decent environment and we can make
that happen we've got the money to do it
there's nothing that standing in our way
except a lack of political will from the
people in that building over there which
means those who have been made poor the
same system that pollutes our oceans
and there is the same system we need to
have people sitting in at their Congress
people's offices at their Senators
offices and telling them we ain't leavin
till you pass a green new deal still a
democracy the people do still rule and
there is a presidential election a
presidential primary that's coming up
there are green new deals that have been
proposed by some of the candidates look
at them find the one that does the best
job that's what I did we that's your
bill Maynes
and incarcerate poor people in this
country we are people that care about
each other our brothers and sisters not
only in this country but all around the
world no interest in bombing and killing
and drone striking other people like us
that are just trying to live we can the
new president the next president of the
United States can turn this around that
president can use their power to unite
the world against a common enemy which
is climate change instead of wasting all
of our resources on killing each other
[Applause]
now you know what their ice cream tastes
so good our Wars of cars is the same
system that takes children away from
their families for not having access to
clean water housing it
[Music]
[Applause]
you